nordrhein westfalen hat jetzt
entschieden dass man die musterung auch
schon nach vier wochen bekommen können
soll man hat dann anschließend noch nach
geklappt hat gesagt nein das ist
natürlich keine empfehlung es ist nur
der mindestabstand aber natürlich wurde
es von der bevölkerung hauptsächlich als
empfehlungen gesehen ich kann mir das
ganze nur so vorstellen dass im
ministerium niemand verstanden hat was
booster überhaupt bedeutet uns nochmal
klarzustellen muss dann bedeutet nicht
möglichst schnell drei spritzen in den
arm irgendeines menschen zu bekommen
ostern ist eine auffrischimpfung nach
einer grundimmunisierung wir machen ja
erst erfahrungen mit dieser impfung und
wir gehen davon aus dass zwei impfungen
mit dem mma impfstoff dem
herauszugreifen oder auch zweimal astra
eine grundimmunisierung macht eine puste
hrung einer auffrischung die kommt dann
nach dieser zweiten impfung und der
abstand der zeitliche abstand zwischen
der zweiten und der dritten impfung ist
entscheidend für das boostern nur das
kann wirklich eine auffrischung eine
tatsächliche nach verstärkung bringen
vier wochen dürfte in den allermeisten
fällen völlig falsch sein und ich frage
mich warum man da nicht den
medizinischen sachverstand eingeholt das
gibt es auch in nordrhein westfalen ganz
hervorragende immunologen man hätte
jeden fragen können ich denke jeder
hätte gesagt mit den vier wochen magst
ausnahmen geben aber für die meisten ist
das der falsche zeitraum die frage ist
ja generell was das boostern betrifft
also ich habe mich zweimal entlassen ich
mache jetzt auch das bus dann aber das
habe ich jetzt auch genau so gesagt wie
es meine ich mache es jetzt aber ich bin
schon ziemlich genervt von der politik
ich mein erst sollte ich zweimal machen
jetzt muss ich wieder machen wann muss
ich denn das nächste mal machen wir
freundin von mir gerade ihr booster
eintragen lassen in der apotheke dann
stand da irgendwie bei der apotheke
vierter hat sie gesagt nee die vierte
hatte ich noch nicht und hat mich
angerufen eine kommt schon die vierte
impfung hab ich gesagt nee ich glaube
nicht klar reise ich bin nicht darüber
informieren und das ist ein bisschen das
problem was ich so habe an diesem an
diesen mustern mit vier wochen das ist
ja ja das verstehe ich schon gar nicht
aber ich frage mich das frage ich sie
als arzt ich bin ja ein laie aber ich
frag mich warum kann man nicht erst ein
antikörpertest machen nachdem man zwei
hatten und wenn der antikörper test an
über 1000 ist dann muss man es ja noch
nicht machen und wenn ich jetzt heute
ein antikörpertest machen würde der lage
bei 300
die erste die morgen sagen würde also
klaus ich hoffe ich kann die sendung
moderiere ich gehe aber erstmal zum
impfen keine lust mich anzustecken kurze
antwort wenn ja was wüssten dann könnte
man das so machen aber das wissen wir
leider noch nicht wir wissen nicht den
cut off wieviel antikörper sind den
haben dass man den haben und nochmal
ganz wichtig auch zu verstehen es ist
nicht der anti es ist nicht die
impfungen die uns die immunabwehr macht
in den immunschutz sondern es ist unser
ureigenstes immunsystem und jeder von
uns so wie hier sitzen hat ein anderes
immunsystem wenn wir älter werden altert
auch das immunsystem das heißt die
impfung trägt ja nur das immunsystem an
deswegen kann man auch nie allgemein
sagen wie lange hält denn jetzt der
impfschutz wirklich an das ist bei jedem
unterschied aber wie kann man eine
allgemeine regel für alle bürger machen
dann mit den sechs- oder drei monaten
die stiko versucht das natürlich und
nimmt nimmt die daten und kommt dann zum
bestmöglichen ergebnis es ist ja richtig
dass diese sechs monate natürlich nie so
exakt sind also von anfang an war klar
das immunsystem hat ja keine uhr oder
kein kalender ob das jetzt 55 halb sechs
das kann man gar nicht genau sagen
vielleicht hat der sahin erfinder von
biotech weit hat er recht wenn er sagt
nach drei monaten muss schon gewusst hat
werden nur vier wochen ist mit
sicherheit für einen reifungsprozess in
das system zu kurz ich kann das nur so
verstehen dass die impfstoff werde
wahrscheinlich gar nicht da gewesen dass
man jetzt jahre alter mann übrigens an
den impfstoff mangel an den glaube ich
noch nicht bis zum beweis des gegenteils
mir scheint dass er so ein typischer
das ist ein popanz aufgebaut wird herr
lauterbach generiert sich ja als
wissenschaftler und jetzt möchte sich
als macher präsentieren ich denke dass
er schon er hat auch schon gesagt in
wenigen tagen dann das tolle ergebnis
sagt ich stehe ja so mit herrn scheinen
ich habe mit allen telefoniert und wenn
ich nicht gewesen wäre hätte den
impfstoff nicht gegeben
nach einstelligen sie mit der sie
unterbrochen lauterbach als macher
würden sie das unterschreiben
na ja das muss erst mal unter beweis
stellen also ich fand jetzt zum beispiel
ich weiß dass das sehr populär ist die
regelung dass ge pustete sich nicht mehr
testen lassen müssen aber ehrlich gesagt
wenn ich höre dass ganz viele die
wirklich vom fach sind sagen ja das
problem ist einfach dass spätestens mit
omikron wahrscheinlich schon mit der
delta variante auch gepostete ansteckend
sind dass sie sich infizieren können und
können es weiter geben sodann kann man
doch einfach nur sagen da wo es kritisch
ist da wo hohes infektionsrisiko ist
dann müssen sich weiterhin alle testen
ich finde es auch widersprüchlich also
die politik macht das ja eigentlich
immer nur um anreize zu setzen also wir
hatten nach dem sommer die 2g regel
super also da keine keine maske kein
abstand zweig paradies waren der
absolute hit das sollte sozusagen die
impfkampagne an motivieren hat aber
eigentlich die vierte welle vorbereitet
weil dann natürlich ganz viele
infektionen stattgefunden haben weil man
ja inzwischen weiß dass geimpfte auch
ansteckend sein können so und jetzt
macht man das gleiche mit dem booster
rungen also nicht mehr testen wir können
auch dann ins fitnessstudio in die bar
überall hin werden waren die ungeimpften
eben selbst getestet komplett aussperrte
können noch nicht mal mehr ein paar
schuhe kaufen dürfen nicht zum friseur
das ist eine völlig also im blick auf
die gesundheitspolitik absolut
kontraproduktiv also da kann ich dann in
lauterbach und nicht ernst nehmen als
sogenannten experten das ist einfach
nicht sinnvoll sondern man sollte jetzt
die dinge tun die wirklich sinnvoll sind
wo man wirklich menschen schützt und ich
wollte gern einen punkt noch sagen das
ist ja auch mit dem musterungen sie
haben sie gerade angesprochen ist sind
natürlich auch viele dinge ich werfe
dass niemand vor dieses virus ist neu
gewesen und die impfstoffe sind auch neu
aber vieles was wir am anfang erhofft
haben was uns die impfung bringt konnte
so nicht bestätigt werden am anfang hat
man gedacht oder zumindest wohl es so
kommuniziert dass die impfstoffe so
wirken wie wie beispielsweise der basen
impfstoff oder der pocken impfstoff das
heißt wenn viele sich impfen rottenburg
war sie sukzessive das virus aus weil es
nicht mehr weitergegeben wird und dann
wäre ich tatsächlich also bei der
pockenimpfung wäre ich wenn man noch
heute pocken hätten wäre ich für eine
impfpflicht ganz klar könnte man also
eine schreckliche krankheit beenden aber
die wäre die jetzt vorhandenen
impfstoffe leisten das nicht also die
hoffnung wenn ganz viele sich impfen
lassen sind wir draußen aus der pandemie
die ist meines erachtens eine falsche
hoffnung wir sehen ja jetzt in ländern
die sehr sehr hohe impfquoten haben
irland zum beispiel dänemark trotzdem
ein irres infektionsgeschehen mehr als
in deutschland und deswegen finde ich
wir sollten nicht so einseitig nur auf
die impfung setzen warum machen wir
nicht mehr frühzeitig wenn einer einen
pcr-test hat und er ist positiv und der
im weitesten sinne zu einer risikogruppe
gehört gibt es ja schon mittel die man
einsetzen kann warum wird das nicht die
leute werden nach hause geschickt sollen
sich isolieren und erst wenn es ganz
schlimm kommt dann rufen sie den
krankenwagen andere länder machen
frühzeitiger etwas ich finde darauf
müssen wir viel mehr setzen ich weiß
nicht was die modernen medikamente uns
bringen aber zumindest gibt es ja jetzt
erste ansätze ich habe auch da die
hoffnung und ich finde wir sollten mehr
mit testen machen also testen nicht nur
gegen den das virus sondern auch
immunität tests also die antikörper
haben sie ja recht die sind vielleicht
nicht so aussagekräftig aber ich habe
mir sagen lassen es gibt inzwischen
testverfahren wo man zum beispiel ganz
klar sehen kann wer hat eine immunität
auch durch andere viren kreuzimmunität
der muss sich ja nicht impfen lassen
oder wer hatte schon mal das virus wer
ist genesen er müsste sich auch nicht
impfen lassen das heißt wenn das
anerkannt würde würden wir auch nicht
diesen logistischen aufwand haben die
ganze bevölkerung immer durch zu impfen
weil die impfpflicht die da jetzt
diskutiert wird das ist glaube ich die
meisten nicht bewusst das ist eine reine
ein info dass da verpflichten würde also
nach allen nach sechs monaten das war
der vorschlag von herrn scholz verfällt
der impfstatus und die eu sagt auch
spätes nach neun monaten verfällt der
gamestar status da muss man sich noch
impfen lassen oder nicht das ist
natürlich ein schwarz weiß sehen also
das sind die mittel die wir gerade haben
und diese mittel sind diese impfstoffe
dass sie nicht perfekt sind ist klar
aber sie helfen sie hält ja klar das
liegt vielleicht auch am kanal aus
weitergeben die helfen auch die
gesundheitssysteme zu entlassen
da und man und ich sehe was ja
verschwörungstheoretiker und ich sehe
was cologne leugner immer wieder
sozusagen an div informationen
weitergeben und wie viele impfstoffe
komplett
kaputt machen in ihre in ihre
darstellung das ist nicht erfahren wir
sind dankbar dass wir diese impfstoffe
haben wäre ein perfekter impfstoff da
dann natürlich perfekt aber das was wir
haben und mit das was wir haben müssen
wir arbeiten und dazu müssen wir die
leute dazu motivieren sich zu impfen vor
allem da wo diese impfung auch
lebensmittel vor allem die risikogruppen
sind da bin ich ja auch absolute
newtv lagen machen und freue mich
ich bin ja immer darauf dass man den
menschen mehr zutrauen können soll als
ihnen zugetraut wird und eigentlich ist
doch das wort risikominimierung also das
allerbeste ist doch man erkrankt nicht
schwer angehoben richtig also das muss
man einfach das gerät in vergessenheit
weil man es denkt das beste ist man
lässt sich impfen oder nicht impfen kann
an das allerbeste ist man erkrankt nicht
schwer ancona und die älter man ist umso
mehr gilt das und jetzt glaube ich dass
man einfach viel mehr animieren müsste
was für jeden einzelnen das richtige ist
also für einen 25-jährigen kern gesunden
menschen ist was anderes richtig als 75
jährigen mit herzerkrankungen und schon
zwei fest
und das glaube ich kann ein mensch
selber für sich ganz gut entscheiden ich
zb fühle mich jetzt durch diese booster
reiben gepustet auch in so eine booster
hysterie versetzt weil für mich ist
risikominimierung abstand klar so ein
bisschen maske wenn ich es für sinnvoll
halte booster toll jetzt wird mir
eingeredet vier wochen sechs wochen
sechs monate abschließen am schluss geht
irgendwie alle drei modelle und wenn es
dann noch eine pflicht gibt und jetzt
gleich dann als bürger als
freiheitsliebender bürger dann wirklich
ein bisschen schäbig wenn es dann noch
eine pflicht gibt dann muss ich mich
womöglich alle drei monate impfen lassen
und das macht den menschen glaube ich
mehr sagen also das wird nicht kommen
aber ganz wichtig das muss ich unbedingt
noch loswerden die impfung wird das
virus nicht eliminieren das ist ein
völliger unsinn das wird das war am
anfang also eine idee das wird nie
funktionieren aber die impfung kann
helfen in der bevölkerung nur dann hört
die pandemie auf eine gewisse
teilimmunität zu entwickeln wir werden
also geimpft sein wir werden uns auch
infizieren auch die geimpften auch die
geposteten wie dürren anderen variante
noch und aber nicht mehr schwer
erkranken und erst wenn das in jahren
das dauert ein paar jahre im jahren zu
einer gewissen teil grund immunität
gekommen ist dann ist die pandemie
vorbei das virus wir können in zehn
jahren in unserer runde hier nochmal ein
stückchen reinstecken und werden saß
kopf zwei finden das sollte uns nicht
irritieren infektion ist nicht
erkrankung infektion ist nur
voraussetzung für die kranke erkrankung
aber in zehn jahren ist es hoffentlich
nicht mehr so dass eine infektion die
erkrankung bedeutet ich wollte einen
ganzen raum sind weil sie ja sozusagen
beschlossen haben sich nicht impfen zu
lassen und eine kluge frau sind mit
meinem argument der risikominimierung
jetzt sieht es nicht an ihm ihr zu sagen
dann ist das risiko dass zu kriegen und
zu erkranken geringer wenn ich das mache
oder was hat sie davon abgehalten weil
es eigentlich lohnt geschieht zum einen
habe ich wirklich noch bestimmte
gesundheitliche gründe warum ich ein
vorbehalt habe gerade bei den aktuell
verfügbaren impfstoffen ich würde mich
sofort im flow impfen lassen mit einem
traditionellen impfstoff und ich finde
es wirklich fahrlässig gibt es ja also
muss man nicht warten die weko hat die
zugelassen die werden weltweit verimpft
milliarden fahre es gibt erfahrungen es
gibt daten ich verstehe nicht warum man
die in der eu nicht anerkennt nicht
zulässt ich glaube ähnlich wie ich würde
das viele menschen sehen also das wäre
das eine und das andere ist eben
tatsächlich klar also ich bin schon
vielleicht am anfang einer risikogruppe
das kann man bei mir sagen aber ich
finde zum beispiel jungen leuten ist es
noch mal anders also wie gesagt jeder
junge mensch der sich impfen lassen will
wunderbar aber junge leute unter druck
zu setzen die nun wirklich nicht das
gesundheitssystem aus den nähten reißen
lassen weil sie kaum auf den
intensivstationen liegen als das ist
meines erachtens nicht okay und ich
finde wirklich ich habe jetzt auch ich
kenne persönlich junge 13-jähriger zum
beispiel die haben wenn den bayern
wohnen und ich glaube auch in anderen
bundesländer ist das inzwischen so
können die nächstes jahr nicht mehr
ihren sport machen also nicht mehr im
basketball spielen nicht mehr im
sportclub sie sind also da einmal sommer
wirklich gesundheitlich beeinträchtigt
wenn man jungen menschen sein sport
wegnimmt natürlich auch sozial
ausgegrenzt und die stiko hatte
ausdrücklich gesagt kinder und das sind
ja 13 14 15 jährige immer noch sollten
nicht unter druck gesetzt werden das
heißt es ist eine ganz absurde politik
die gemacht und da wird ebenso getan
habe um die pandemie zu überwinden
müssten wir das machen und das halte ich
für unsinn ich sehe dass es ein problem
gibt bei den älteren jahrgängen wo es
zwar eine impfquote gibt so zwischen 86
und 90 wir wissen ja noch nicht mal
genau wie hoch sie ist in deutschland
muss man auch immer wieder dazu sagen
unsere datenerhebung ist ja wirklich
brillant aber sie ist so in etwa
zwischen 86 und 90 prozent bei den über
60-jährigen so da sind immer noch so
ungefähr zwei bis drei millionen nicht
geimpft die sind haben ein großes risiko
und das muss man auch immer ganz klar
aussprechen das ist ein problem und ich
bin auch froh dass wir die impfstoffe
haben ich weiß nicht wie wir durch die
vierte welle gekommen wären ohne impfung
also das möchte ich mir nicht ausmalen
aber diese art wie man unter druck wie
man alles über einen kamm schert wie man
junge leute jetzt ausgrenzt wie man
überhaupt menschen auch teilweise in
ihrer persönlichen existenz sie
gefährdet weil sie aus verschiedensten
und teilweise nachvollziehbaren gründen
sich anders entscheiden das kann ich
wirklich nicht verstehen und halte ich
auch nicht für sinnvoll da schmeckt hier
noch ganz kurz die ihre medizinische
einschätzung
also nochmal kosten tod impfstoffen weil
das glaube ich kenne jeder zuschauer von
ihnen dass sie sagen ich lass mich dich
empfinde ich warte auf die tote
impfstoffe ich denke da ist doch eine
etwas falsche denke dahinter vielleicht
müssen sie ein anderes argument finden
tod impfstoffe sind die die sich nicht
vermehren können also man hat ja früher
viren gehabt zum beispiel bei masern ist
auch so die können sich vermehrt die
impfstoffe die jetzt für empfehlen sind
alles tot im stoff eingenähte sie haben
schon neues genetisches verfahren das
ist ein anderes verfahren ja ja aber
dass wir haben das nicht so viel zeit
aber
diese m rna ich weiß nicht wo ihre
ängste da sind das ist auch dann zu
privat wenn sie sagen sie haben
gesundheitliche aspekte das muss man
dann anschließend besprechen aber diese
m rna ist ja kein genetischer schnipsel
der sich bei ihnen irgendwo einbauen
kann das tut ja nicht einer geht auch
nicht in diez in den zellkern sondern
dem das problem ist auch nicht dass der
zu lange existiert sondern das problem
war immer da solange wenigstens haltbar
zu machen im körper dass es wenigstens
in die zelle hinein kommt um seine
tätigkeit zu tun also es ist eher
umgekehrt die männer ist sehr sehr
anfällig und man hat es hingekriegt mit
dieser verkapselung dass das eben so
lange funktioniert aber die mnh wird
sehr schnell abgebaut 12 wochen danach
da nichts mehr das ist keine dauer
impfung und sie produzieren auch nicht
dauernd dieses bike protein sondern nur
am anfang der impfung also von daher
diese angst müssen sie wirklich nicht
haben und die tod impfstoffe diese
angesprochen haben die müssen ja erst
noch nachweisen dass sie tatsächlich so
ist es etwa